salut c'est julian élus moi c'est
olivier et pendant ce temps là dans la
creuse participe aux championnats
d'europe de la coupe mulet
des gens aujourd'hui me définissent par
l'univers
et attend de combinés
au japon après avoir le premier primé
mémoire faire partie d'une grande course
est déjà bien bandage
[Musique]
alors on a des gens qui viennent de
partout en france on a des gens viennent
de belgique on a un portugais on a pas
mal de swiss re catégorie de lully mais
sur un mulet plutôt naissant en loisir
on est sur un mulet plus tôt
on est un vétéran ou traditionnelles et
catégories de mulets on est sur un mulet
plutôt confirmé là
on a des mulets naissant les mulets
vétérans les mille et dégarni les mulets
moderne les milieux traditionnels ému
les enfants les mulets femmes et les
mulets couple et les mulets non binaire
c'est la deuxième édition de ce
championnat cette année ils sont une
centaine à concourir pour le prix de la
plus belle coupe mulet d'europe élu à
l'applaudimètre le vainqueur de cette
année est ici ils défendent l'anti
conformisme et l'autodérision la
philosophie à l'est on sait ce qu'on
porte on sait que ça plaît pas à tout le
monde on sait que ça peut être parfois
vu comme quelque chose de très beau
futur vraiment très très arriérée a
parfois peut-être des personnages un peu
simplet l'idée c'est de dire venez
creusé dans cette carapace des mois un
petit petit j'en ai fait d'autres
anticonformiste pour moi celui de casser
les codes en fait d'eux les diktats de
la beauté ou de la mode de pouvoir
surfer dessus pour rigoler
nico de belgique 32 ans je me sens bien
comme je suis je m'assume avec la coupe
même si les gens viennent me dire coupe
des cheveux s'appuie la mode
c'est pas moi alors moi je reste moi
même
mois
[Musique]
ça
fait plaisir à tous mon frigo et ouais
c'est à dire des gens
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui oui
on n'est pas là autant
d'applaudissements
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
que du bonheur en vrai c'était très très
drôle le public est là malgré le temps
pourri c'est vraiment ça gagne quoi
avec ça applaudit ce que les gens
réagissent et des passages
[Musique]
terminez du coup je voulais pas seul je
crois qu'on s'est passé en cp une bonne
trésorerie en vrai
[Musique]
c'est juste profiter fini maintenant est
passé le plus dur est passé du bonheur
le prix du public est décerné au numéro
63 le papy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le vainqueur de cette année et m
toi
[Applaudissements]
et on
2 vous
du vrai
ouais
oui
[Applaudissements]
ça me fait vraiment énormément plaisir
que ce soit contre remettra le trophée
voilà donc un petit trophée avec mes
cheveux l'intérieur j'espère que tu
pourras à faire plus tu la tradition je
vous remercie infiniment
infiniment 2 de toutes les gloires
combat populaire
[Applaudissements]
germaine la plupart belgique
tu es content ce soir
mais ses classes à tous les gens qui
m'ont appris grâce à eux qu'il faut ce
que je suis aujourd'hui
le king